There's a, um, a new documentary
by the guy wrote Copay,
cocaine cowboys did cocaine cowboys
and a bunch of other documentaries.
Billy Korb. Yup. Billy court. Corbin,
you got it. Oh, don't, why
did I choke on his lane?
Some water. Anyway, Billy has a new
documentary are called screen a screwball.
Yeah.
It's all about Alex Rodriguez and the
steroids scandal and a w one of the guys
in it as a fake doctor who would
wear a stethoscope around his neck.
Like he got his,
he got his degree in some Janky overseas
university and wasn't legal to practice
medicine in the United States,
but he would call himself a doctor and
he had like the stethoscope that you'd
wear. Well, and his office, he'd walk
around with a stethoscope around his neck,
like hanging around his neck.
I just think he's going to
check your heart meatball.
All he's doing is prescribing
steroids cause it was amazing.
This kid that was walking around,
he posed as a doctor and had multiple
patients and got it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember this is in Florida,
the same play I guess in Florida too.
It must be pretty easy. Of course
it's in Florida. Is this name?
Does his name say Malakai?
Uh, yeah, like a creepy name.
That's like children of the corn
that's like, how do you pronounce that?
Malika Malakai. Yeah, that's, that
is ballsy. Do W wait a minute.
That's not his real name. Mary
Malakai Love Robinson. Why not?
That sounds like a character from
like some sort of porno. There he is.
Dr Malakai,
a Fasti Fasti,
h h p Dash c a m p dash CV
death or all those things,
HIV. What are all those other things
that he is a health care proxy?
Maybe some bullshit amp.
I don't know what the hell that
sounds like a gas station in Kansas.
Let's read his,
his thing let's says is a well doctor
Malakai a love Robinson is a well rounded
professional that treats and cares for
patients using a system of practice at
basis,
treatment on physiological functions
and abnormal conditions on natural laws
governing the human body. That doesn't
even, that's a run on sentence.
You missed it. Hold on a
second. Docs would love.
Robinson utilizes physiological,
electrical and mechanical
methods such as air,
water, light, heat, earth, photo therapy,
food and herbs, therapy,
psychotherapy, electro therapy,
physio therapy,
mechano therapy,
natural path corrections and manipulation
and natural methods or modalities
together with natural medicines,
natural process foods and herbs
and nature's remedies. Cool. Oh,
what you just said? The only thing that
was true about that was manipulation.
Well, how is this guy like who, who
read that and went, all right. Yeah,
we're in. Yeah. Who read that was
like, I need to make an appointment.
Immediately found the real doctor.
All this other bullshit doctors
that don't use manipulation.
One doctor goes like this in a photo.
All of them.
Now imagine that became the new thing.
I would not go to that doctor. Huh?
Get offices. So someone had to like rent
him the spot. So they believed them too.
Not just the patient or he
at least had an off a office,
like an office guy whose dad could have
a bullshitter that pretends to be a
doctor, actually gets patients. It's
got a stethoscope. Got a website.
Isn't that good?
It's good enough that he's got
patients like it actually worked.
Like imagine being so crazy that
you tell everybody you're a doctor.
You don't know shit about biomedical
medical practices. You know,
you read his little bio there and you
get offices and then you get patients,
you treating patients.